hey how's it going bros my name is
grandpa welcome to Oracle survival evil
it's the new survivor game just what
everyone wanted didn't they I don't know
anything about this game the trailer
looked cool some I thought would check
it out together so part of me if I don't
know how to play the game will discover
it together like a like a friendship
ah so here we are holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
where am I going I know nobody's knowing
i Chuck a dose of fabric yeah where the
wind sorry it's the only rap line I know
alright next sighs BAM neck length Pam
chest BAM
shoulders bad man you know what
all right fine Bab whoa whoa yes yes yes
yes oh my god you look so good that is a
nice [ __ ] camel toe you can fit a
whole [ __ ] Pringles boxy okay uh
tours BAM
oh yeah [ __ ] love character creations
oh yes holy [ __ ] those biceps there's
like 50 hamburgers in there survivor
named salad has obviously uh oh uh I
said it's so bright but oh my giant
biceps my giant I ditch ha's oh this is
really cool what the [ __ ] man man what
the [ __ ] jack said this game wasn't cool
how do I go in third person so I can
look at my pecs and I can punch people
or jerked him off well what is that this
is very halo I like it there we go yeah
baby I'm ready ready to rock
yay Wow all right let's go baby
so I guess our objective is to survive
on this island and it's at a unicorn
it's a unicorn horn oh my god that's
amazing some fiber more fiber all right
all Jabari my favorite cuz you can just
look at me go look at those muscles
working
sexy sexy sexy sexy
how are those underwear still holding up
oh [ __ ]
the [ __ ] is is minecraft minecraft' Oh
stupid drink a punch you curse I'm a man
and that's what we do
bet you like that [ __ ] don't you yes I
do please sighs Oh boots one tree zero
whoa
pepper about pepper and the best
survivor I'm a survivor can't hit the
rock can't seem to hit it there you go
you stupid stupa is awesome
did I just [ __ ] my pants oh my god
that's awesome hey parents how you doing
did I just pick it up [ __ ] man why did
where are you going you little [ __ ] stop
throwing away pants I left you for a
reason
all right you know what a little [ __ ]
I'll set you free in the sea
there you go [ __ ] you're free
thanks Pierce
goodbye poop I love you all right so we
need to get a spear going for that we
need some more wood so let's punch them
tree stupid let's build a spear let boom
I was pretty sick ha ha ha can I throw
it can I throw it oh okay I got it I got
it right I didn't lose it right where
the [ __ ] is my spear where is it
where the [ __ ] did it go where the [ __ ]
did my spear go spear
pants sphere where are you you don't
know what you got until it's gone all
right we're gonna have to go with Plan B
here and take a swim we need your cold
[ __ ] please I'm not cold all right
there's something green and [ __ ] going
on here ah what the [ __ ] was he can't
just kill me all right we're gonna have
to start off in the beginning great oh
[ __ ] it instead of [ __ ] dying it what
the [ __ ] is dinosaurs doing here
run Charlotte ass run for your life I
think we're safe now let's go hunt some
Dennis's oh yeah oh my [ __ ] god what
the [ __ ] is that hey there little fella
how you doing hey puss I'm a big fan
oh really now are you a big fan are you
how about this nah brah oh [ __ ] my spear
broke Plan B what the [ __ ] ah I'm so
Pitt the [ __ ] are you laughing eh
what the [ __ ] are you punch you
I'll punch you I don't like your
attitude oh god he has friends oh [ __ ]
come back here I need you your dinner
come here you piece of [ __ ] I killed him
yes I'm a man America sweet Sweden
Sweden oh my god is that my old body huh
it is that's hot
so sexy can I eat me
now this is some weird ass [ __ ]
cannibalism going on oh no don't judge
me
this is called survivalists ISM I ate
myself what a day thanks to me you saved
my life
this is ridiculous
yeah salad ass Advent damn it adventures
of salad eNOS badass you think you're a
badass well and you haven't seen a salad
ASF yeah this is really cool this game I
really enjoy it only thing is the
framerate is really bad bye why are you
going to it's a new game I bet there
will optimize it eventually as in right
isn't that right salad ass that's fried
pants I just that boys really doesn't
fit really does not alright you know
what I think this will be a great time
to end this episode bros if you want
more I would love to continue this as a
series if you enjoyed leave a like
really appreciate it and I will see you
bros in the next one as always thanks
for watching
stay awesome bros don't listen to him
Marjorie shut up I don't need a [ __ ]
George oh this could be good
flippers